let's talk about you I remembered seeing
you for the first time as a child
because you were child actress yes
you got started well I think of a lot of
kids who get into acting early as being
hyper creative having great imaginations
maybe were you that kind of give you the
kind of kid that sort of was able to go
into your own world when I was an only
child so I all I had was my imagination
and yeah I I had a I had a really
luxurious collection of Barbies that I
would I had a whole world for me too did
you know I I didn't have Barbies I have
a GI Joe
but but Barbies you had Barbies and and
what was so I mean a lot of kids have
Barbies a lot of young girls have
Barbies yeah what was creative about it
well I mean I didn't think that it was
so different at the time but now you
know growing up I would look back and I
go oh that was probably really
precocious and strange but I I had my
father had some carpet samples because
he had a restaurant and they were in the
basement so I laid all those out and
kind of made a gridded neighborhood for
them and had addresses for them and any
had a copy machines so I in order to
keep like my friends who had come and
and want to play with them to keep them
on track right I had to identify them
and tell them where they were in
whatever lives they were leading so I
had I copied their faces I know
wait a minute you sorry I mean over
various doctor living
you've got to living in like a Barbie
Guantanamo Bay
you've got segmented sections and then
you also have you creating separate
identities and how realistic are these
identities with it like well what I did
what I mean I copied their faces and and
made little you know little like
passport photo type things for their IDs
I put on that you know put down their
occupations their age their address
laminated those pieces of paper with
scotch tape so they were like official
IDs Wow and I kept them on the box and
and it got it just got very very very
involved there was you know how there's
always a Barbie that's not really
Mattel Barbie it's kind of like the the
drugs
brand yes and she's you know and like
you know got kinda it's not that nice
vinyl and looks like there's hair plugs
yeah so she became like the village
alcoholic then you have a whole story
for her oh yeah oh she's into this race
trouble she was really she was the
problem because and then I affixed like
a Barbie bottle to her hand that just
never left her hand sure and and she had
like a skipper you know brand doll who
had a different name that I came up with
who she lost custody of and she had to
go with her aunt and then she couldn't
she knew she had a teenage pregnancy it
was very so oh okay I get the pregnancy
too I like I like gave them bumps okay
okay that's that's really sick that's
like really like someone should call
child services and have you that's won't
you like you'd think this child needs to
talk to somebody because well that's
what my Barbies were formed yeah yeah
your Barbies were busy they were in
court I'd like to tell blaze I play with
my Barbies neighbor they're all tied up
in court yeah hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please